welcome to the july 2022 meetup this is
our second month both back in person
and virtual so it's good to have
everyone
a reminder for those of you um virtual
we have two ways you can chat with us
there is the youtube chat right where
you're watching this you can chat right
on youtube we will be watching that if
you have a question we will ask it of
our speaker
throughout the question session
you can also use the monthly meetup chat
in our slack channel
and you can find that by going to
nyhackguard.org and clicking the little
slack icon that's how you find that
so before we even get started actually
before we do that i'll just say jobs
anyone in the room hiring
nom you're hiring now
no no i'm not hiring okay um i'm hiring
an account executive and
a part-time data scientist or full-time
depending remote full remote whatever
you're looking for
if you are virtual and you are hiring
and you obviously can't tell us because
you know you can't stand up in the room
and say hi
go to the job postings channel of the ny
hacker slack and you can let us know
that you are looking for a job there or
that you're hiring actually if you're
hiring post a job if you're looking for
a job and you feel comfortable saying it
tell people you're looking we've gotten
many many many people jobs over the past
13 plus years of this meetup so we'd
like to get more people jobs
all right
other things august
we'll have that announced pretty soon
we'll have the august meet up and then
september and so on and so forth we'd
like to thank microsoft for hosting us
here in their beautiful times square
offices
we had the new york r conference last
month and some of you might have noticed
that the videos are up online at the
rstats.ai website and and on our youtube
channel
and we will be putting out a more formal
announcement about that so if you want
to check out the videos from
this past year's and actually all the
years of the conference go to rstats.ai
to find it
we can put that link in the youtube chat
so people can get to it
if you're looking for previous videos of
this meetup and slideshows you can go to
nyhackguard.org i keep mentioning that
and you can find about 13 years worth of
slideshows and six to eight years worth
of videos depending how many still exist
on the various streaming services we
have used over the years
i think that's all the announcements we
have coming up because it's summer
things a little slower we will have a
stand workshop coming up sometime maybe
august september we usually do the stand
workshop every summer uh we'll see what
time we do it this year we say you know
it's a it's a pandemic year so we're
still figuring it out
other than that i think that's all the
normal announcements we usually have i'm
going to check my phone really quickly
in case nicole's shouting at me telling
me there's other announcements no i
don't think there are so
oh yeah i forgot one more thing people
in the room the pizza is from pizzeria's
pizza so if you go to bit.lee pizza poll
vote on the pizza we've had this poll
running for
10 years now or whatever for a long time
and you can see that we actually have a
live data vis if you go to
nyhackguard.org you can see a live
javascript visualization of the pizza
poll it's over in the room bitly dot bit
dot lease pizza poll and let us know how
the pizza is it's from pizzeria and you
know rank it on a scale from never again
poor excellent go average good excellent
and check it out
we know we love our pizza here
all right i think that's all the
announcements i have i forget anything
i'm sure i could tell you at the end
some of you may have noticed if you
didn't notice you're in for a surprise
that
hugo is not speaking right now
um are you surprised
okay cool let's look at someone so
basically hugo came all the way from
australia for other reasons but he was
supposed to speak tonight and this
morning he sent me a text that
he was had a fever and he was coughing
he had a negative covet test but he
still said let's not come here which is
a smart move
so luckily we had someone from not quite
as far away but at least a different
hemisphere only one different hemisphere
not two hemispheres who on about a few
hours notice
uh about six hours notice seven hours
notice said sure i can speak
so i wanna have before even to introduce
him just a round of applause for karil
for doing that golf clap of your virtual
he's spoken here before about dm which
he's going to be speaking about again
tonight so i am very excited to
see what has changed in the patchy the
last time he spoke was one of our last
meetups before the pandemic started
interesting timing by the way
and
we're all looking forward to everything
that's changed since then so everyone
please give a warm welcome before we
give a warm welcome remember if you're
virtual and you have questions put it in
the youtube chat and i will ask the
question of krill later all right if
you're in person when we have questions
just raise your hand and ask the
question right we all remember how to do
that hopefully so you know first time
we've been back in person a while it's
only our second in person meetup so
everyone hope you have a great virtual
time hope you have a great in-person
time hope you enjoy the pizza and
virtual people
if you got pizza let us know where you
got it from if you got some inferior
food let us know where you got that from
too all right let us know let's have a
good time enjoying our food virtually of
each other with that please everyone
virtually give us an emoji in person
karil thank you for filling in for us
that was awesome for you
let me give you the mic
so does the sound work
it will work you're not going to hear
the speakers because it's purely on um
it's purely in the
flight drive
okay so
thank you
for
the opportunity to speak tonight here
it's been
a couple of years and a bit
since
we were here last time
also with my two daughters here
also visiting new york on the move to dc
so
it was just great timing i asked jared
before
i was coming here and he said no the
meter was full so well
i guess that's just how life is
sometimes
this is
my presentation or a version of the
presentation i'm going to show it our
studio conf it's
tables it's a bit scary isn't it so
we
wanted to build a shiny app that would
allow us to filter
in this
data set consisting of multiple tables
in all those various tables
to get details about the result set and
we did this we built
800
lines of
variant
of the code shown here in the end and
the best thing about this when the data
model changes the code just stays the
same this wouldn't have been possible
with the original joining code so i
called it a success
others called it a success two
amazing treasure lifesaver so niels uh
gary cadley thanks a lot
and thanks for everybody who filed
issues and
contributed pull requests to the package
you're awesome
now
i still have one day to make this happen
you're bad
okeydoke
the m version one is still not on crown
i'm sorry about that sometimes the
internet just doesn't do what
we wanted to do
but it will be today or tomorrow
so we are stable
and
you can try today
from github
from our universe you can try tomorrow
from crown and there is an art studio
cloud
setup that will
get you an
a remoter studio session with everything
pre-installed
with a click of a button
so
yeah this list just has grown
we
have a ton of dependencies and we're
kind of
proud of it because it wouldn't have
been possible to build
a thing like we built without all those
amazing people helping us building
groundwork so
kudos as well here
yeah this is us right
and
maybe you have seen this before
but i'm going to repurpose this meme
today
so
um
which of these tools has the notion of
the active data set right
can you guess so one car one data set
many cars many data sets it's that
simple r doesn't have the active data
set and that's a good thing
so
it took me a while to realize that
data management is a bit different from
data analysis so
this is the form of
data you would probably like to have for
analyzing data
you have one table you have all your
data lined up rows columns cells with
atomic values
it's all great except there's
duplication in those highlighted parts
on the left
now duplication isn't great if you want
to clean or manage your data
if you try it
white
form that's better except
it's not those those column names make
me
want to transform this into longer form
just right after i see this so
yeah one table is not enough
and the conclusion is the consequence is
we want the m because that's what the m
is doing helping us with
handling more than one table
right so
you're probably familiar with those
concepts very briefly
at the top
right
that's what a dm object contains tables
primary keys foreign keys
the data set we've seen before can be
decomposed into two tables
one
entity table at the right a measurement
table
at the left we have
measurements linking to entities
there's a foreign key from the
measurement to the entity and two
primary keys that's what it looks like
with the
dm package
so
that's the part where the demo comes i
don't have the video recorded yet so
which is
which means i'm going to do this live
we have
a new shiny app that gets you started
with the n
because
really it's
a lot of
material to read
just to get started it's unsure it's
unclear will it help you
right away or will it just make your
life more complicated
i think
we have since
we spoke last time made a few
improvements that help you
get started easier
and
that
help integrate
the package into
your workflows a bit better so here it
comes
the shiny app
that
would help you
in two cases so first when connecting to
a database and you see something like
this this is adventure works if you're
familiar with that
help you find your ways and get
something that's a bit easier to work
with so i could
zoom in i could pick the tables
i want
maybe this
maybe this i don't know
is this useful let's see
i'm going to select
oh no i don't know job candidate
i don't need job can do that
so probably i'm going to need to select
all of them again but
i'm sure this can be worked on
so i'm building not
the
data model
that i'm getting code
that will give me a demo a dm object
based on what i have on database with
the real data behind it
so i can instantiate it i can draw it
and i can work with it
so
from database
to a dm object that's
i would say
just like connecting is
um
once you're connected to the database
you have half of your work done this
this would be kind of the other half we
help you here you have the
uh
data the normalized data ready for your
further
uh preparation rearrangement
in the r session
as lazy tables so we rely on dbplier
to keep this on the database for as long
as possible so that we don't
unnecessarily get all the data ahead of
time
in the other case
when we're starting with data frames
the user interface helps us here as well
so
i have no idea why this is happening
so let me just retry
okay
so
data frames don't know
about primary keys or foreign keys so we
have to teach them so this is the nvc
flights data which is used throughout
the dm package and it also lives in a
separate package so
if i read the documentation i know faa
is a
primary key
in this table
airlines has
carry as a primary key
and for the planes we have the tail numb
and once we have that
we can start linking the tables together
so
if tail number is the primary key
maybe
lucky
no i need to select it
i can
select
the tables add the keys
with immediate visual feedback
so
i mean i guess you get the idea
so that's the new shiny app oh yeah of
course what would that be without
coloring
oh
i messed up
and it is tricky
i do the undo and you get the code into
your console ready to copy paste into
your r script so that this is
for
you to be used
not only once but
throughout the work with
throughout your work with this data
[Music]
okay
the other major improvement
so this is again the flights data the
other major improvement consists in
helping analyze
the data with dm so
for a long time we had the concept of
zooming
which looks like this so there will be
an animation
if
we aggregate the flights table
let's say
we count the number of flights by origin
or we compute some average delay by
origin or something
that's a group i summarize in deep flyer
and if we zoom
we can zoom into the table perform the
aggregation and get the results and that
results going to be connected
with
the
table
with the airports table that
the
origin column points too
because it's smart about it so
the irrigation
has
led to a new primary and foreign key
determined automatically
and we also get help with joins so if we
when zooming into flights
say electron airports we can omit
telling which columns to join by because
of course the relationship is inferred
from
the data model
so
but i believe zooming is a concept
that's
difficult to
to grasp
more or less
but
what could be even a larger obstacle is
if you have existing code you're not
going to rewrite everything
just to use zoom
is why
we worked on the way to
deconstruct
vm object
into separate tables
have deep plier the idr verbs work
with the deconstructed tables
keeping the features that we had in
zooming so we know about drawing columns
we know what happens after a summarize
and we can later put it put it together
into a new dm object
and
primary and foreign keys will be
inferred
from
those separate tables and
before we ask how does this work i'm not
going to tell you now but we can talk
about it later
uh
should we do a live demo maybe let's do
live demo
nothing can go wrong
and it's all well prepared and
short-term memory
so i'm gonna
remove this
because that's gonna confuse otherwise
so again flight stator
is this large enough probably it's not
i'm gonna need
this to be
visible
okay
so
the mktables
is old
keyed equals true is new so when we do
this
and
we look at what flight becomes
slides the central fact table
we see that it
knows about the keys so the encoding is
a bit confusing there's a primary key
but
no incoming and for
outgoing foreign keys in this table
same if you look at airports
primary key every air column
one incoming foreign key
so if we do the join
note
it's not talking to us about uh this is
by something no it knows that this is
the join that i'm intending to do
and everything just works and
this wouldn't have to work with the
flights data because the columns are
named differently
right
that is with the flights data
from the
package
with keyed tables this works
so
same with the aggregation
if i aggregate by origin
i get
all those foreign keys so
it's
just one in reality but but it's
displaying me it's four and
when i put everything together
it is
the resulting data model
that has
by origin as a new table
with foreign keys in front and i have no
idea why the primary key is not inferred
i'm going to look into that
so this is to sum up what we want to
achieve
so the md construct
doesn't quite exist yet but we will
probably make it part of the shiny app
we will get the code that
gets us
table
objects from the dm object which we then
can plug into our
dplyr workflows
as usual and when putting it back
together it will keep the
primary and foreign keys
so i'm going to show a couple of use
cases here
the first is
a shiny app that
replaces
robust well not so much it replaces an
excel workflow
so this is for managing contracts
we have
a two-stage process
individual contracts that have to be
specified with some detail which then
are grouped together in the second stage
and
this gives an overall contract so think
about companies operating multi
multinationally
that
where each individual contract would
correspond to one country
right this is a screenshot of the first
stage so we see the database front end
projects code families quotes and so
forth that's the data model behind it as
a dm
the first stage is at the bottom and in
the orangish colors the second stage
comes at the top
and what we can do with dm
is
we can read
a quote
with all these details
get it
into our local r session
as data frames in one swoop
operate on it
put it back to the database
very simple with dm if we had to
code it by hand it would have been a bit
repetitive still possible
i believe dm is making this easier plus
of course with all these relationships
in our r session we can
reason about the data easier than
if we just had decomposed tables
especially since the second stage has a
link to the first stage things become a
bit a bit hairy
when working on this
and and other projects
something
has has become apparent
that was was hidden before it comes at
the sv as the big
idea on the last slide that maybe i can
i could just as well talk talk about it
now
so
if you think about this data if you
think about
the quote and all the details for the
quote and maybe with details of the
corresponding code family
and the project
representing this as a bunch of related
tables
is close to the database
but maybe that's not the most natural
way to work with this kind of data
and nested tables nested and packed
tables
are gaining traction so there is first
class support in arrow
which is the de facto standard for
analytic data that's
coming up and
getting a lot of traction
built in support for inductee b postgres
had them so
we could represent the quote
and all the details and also all the
quotes at once as one nested table
with details on coverage
and on the subsequent
tables
in nested columns
details on the quote family
and on a project in packed columns
and we have a function in the m to
achieve this so
we start with quote and dm wrap table
that's what the function is called
show a demo later but it's not planned
converts this thing into one single
nested
data frame automatically and we're
getting database support in the next
release not now
it's a bit hairy in in itself with
databases
and on the other end of the spectrum so
if this was a web api what would the
response look like
if we ask for a quote in all the details
it would be a json
with
all those details
in deeply nested
items
and from json we get to
the same nested
table nested data frame
with the amazing tipleyfire package
which is on cron again as well which i
think is
enormously underrated for what it can do
because
together dm and typify can do the bridge
from deeply nested data to relational
data model and vice versa seamlessly and
automatically
ish
there is a bit
of detail here again i'm going to just
skip that
i think dm version 2 will be
more about making this really really
straightforward for now
we have
help with working with relational data
model and that's
very useful in itself
now we've shown this before i have shown
this before
so
why restrict ourselves to a single data
model
because well we are r we can do anything
we want
for another customer we have
used the m
in a
complex etl pipeline
each box in this diagram would be
a data model in itself the arrows
represent transformations between those
data models each each stage we call them
stages
gives
better guarantees for data integrity
data quality and so forth
and at the right hand side we have
data sets that are
ready for analysis
flat or
sometimes nested
there is no
built-in support for for this kind of of
etl it's a bit hand written right now
but
i believe this is also better suited
to be presented in documentation rather
than having a framework for this because
it's going to be difficult to
make this work for everybody's use cases
so i talked about this
and
yeah this is us so i
had great help from
my team at syncra which
for for preparing the
release of version one
and
yeah
if you're interested in our studio
server installation
or connect installation or in general
our
consulting we'd be happy to talk about
it
that's all i had for today
[Applause]
chat all right so but stay up there
there's questions
you don't get a lead
all right uh we need a typical dollar
sign flights
uh does that copy the data to a new
object or does that
just point to the
data that lives in vm
so
does this question relate to
the database or the data frame scenario
the data frame scenario so earlier when
you there was a thing like keep tables
was an argument you said it's a new
argument
and then you did like flights guests
flights yeah
something that's
maybe important to point out
the ms
fits in into how the tidal verse
thinks
in the sense that
all the m objects are immutable
so with any operation
on a dm object you get a new dm object
we never alter data in place except in
one
case that helps us with the
contracts project but it says then in
place equals true
for everything else you get a copy but r
has copy on
right
passed by reference copy and write
which
reduces the burden on copying the data
it doesn't eliminate it
but if you just put in
a data frame that's a million rows into
a dm object you're not going to copy
data just
with this process
does that answer the question it does
and then i guess i'll follow up with
that
when you're creating the dm object at a
bunch of data frames you're not
duplicating memory because of the path
by reference because of how our works so
we're just
like using this feature
i have another question from virtualland
are there still limitations about
creating a cycle between tables
glad you asked so
what's very new in vm version 1
maybe with this will be 101 just because
crown closes tomorrow
let me fire up the shiny app again
so we have a new
operation called remove cycles
and
it is confusing because that's really
the simplest case we have parallel edges
and what remove cycles does with
parallel edges
is something like this
we duplicate the target table
and that removes the cycles
and from then on this those are
independent
tables conceptually like views on the
same data
and
we don't have this restriction anymore
now
this operation requires a starting table
and
this is important because
depending on what your unit of analysis
is so the starting table would be
roughly the unit of analysis if we're
looking at airports
and remove the cycles the result look it
looks like this
come on
the result the
result looks like this
we're duplicating everything
except the airports table
but
if you think about it we're analyzing
airports by origin airports by
destination we need
those copies
if those would be wrapped into a nested
table
we would have the copy of the flights
data for origin and the copy of the
flight data for destination so for us it
kind of makes sense and this was the
initial motivation for building the
shiny app just this operation because
this is so
mind-bogglingly confusing
the button gives us the preview
and we believe that's going to be the
solution in the past seasons when i
tried to point to like an entire
postgres database
it couldn't pick up the keys
and i'm wondering if that's because i
know there's two different releases with
three different ways to interact with
post browsers they are postgres package
postgres package and odbc package
is there an issue with like using the
right driver package
so
if you had
if this behavior is different
depending on the driver package we
have to look into it
because
schema discovery is
inconsistent
as hell
across databases so we're special casing
basically for every database we care
about which at this time are postgres
sql server of course
maria
ductdb is going to be our first class
citizen
very soon this
they need to sort a few things out and
we might help with that
and of course sqlite
but everything else we will have to do
on a case-by-case basis so if it doesn't
work
you can always do it by hand it could
work a bit better than it used before
because what i haven't presented here is
a
concept for
describing the metadata
in a database agnostic way so there is
now this we call it meter
format and we have adapters for the
different databases and
we hope that
this will make it easier for us to
support databases that might
not work today
could be an option well no
i don't think
dbi is the right place for this maybe
the dm maintainer would be
quite personal
i have a question along those lines so
can you use
vm to set
the keys in the database
so if you have a database what you don't
have keys to find
right and
oh that says that's a very interesting
thing
so
you're proposing the situation when you
have existing tables
that you don't want to recreate but you
just want to add the foreign keys
and primary keys
not yet
but
this does seem interesting what what
what
has a very
limited and a good amount of rudimentary
apis for writing into databases because
it's much more common that people pull
from databases manipulate databases
yes but some of that has changed
recently too yeah i mean
there's a little more of that in
in
everything and this is one of them in
terms of like when you are you know
setting up and building a database you
know we end up doing that primarily in
r2 but you end up
writing sql to do it to set your
set types
and set keys and do things like that and
so
sometimes
it's just that rather than teach the
team to write
the sqls that assemble the database
structure
[Music]
so
what you can do today is
take your data model object
and copy it to the database create
tables primary keys and foreign keys in
one operation it's not possible to
separate those two but i believe this
could already work for you so
let me give you a bit of detail of
how how we we implemented this so there
is a kind of a chicken neck problem
let me explain so each of these arrows
is a transformation
and how do we know the result of the
data transformation without executing it
so in general we don't but in r we can
actually execute
this transformation on a zero from zero
zero row dm object
on the database or
locally
and i mean on a database if you don't
execute it
it
doesn't matter if it has
any rows in it or not
executing will give you the
structure we call it p-type
of the target data model
so
when building a new stage
so this is the process of many
iterations where we didn't pull it at
once we'll build a new stage we start
with the compute function
so the compute function gives us
basing on one or several input
stages
the resulting output stage and we can
run this with zero rows to get the
structure of the output stage
we write it to the database just the
structure tables primary keys foreign
keys
and then we use the same compute
function
to populate it with the data
so we get a dm object that describes
for the case where you do a full load
so it's
it's a bit different with incremental
load but in the case of a full load we
get a dm object that has the data
as lazy tables
and we just copy all of them
at once into the existing structure so
we always separate creation
of the target schema from population
you
create a dm object that has the
structure
you
[Music]
write it to the database without the
data
just the structure and this gets you
tables primary keys foreign keys out of
the box for the major databases
and then
you run this with the data
and you get
your target data as lazy tables on the
database
or if you have this local data frames
that's also cool you have to copy them
to the database and actually write them
to the table but dm has good support for
this so i shall definitely write this
down into a an article at some point
maybe not today
but
we can we can should we talk about
details
later
so there is a dm underscore rows api and
that's what i was mentioning so deep
flyer has gained
a new rows underscore api rows insert
rows append
that was important for the m to have
rows update and support
that takes a target
data set as an x argument and the source
data set as a y argument and so for
instance for rows append it will
unconditionally add the rows and y to x
now the in place argument
describes if this is a preview
in place false gives you a preview which
is pretty cool in itself
in place true requires the target to be
something that you can write to and it
will actually
put the data into your database and we
have extended this with the m rows
insert depend update and so forth
so it's not as useful as it sounds
unfortunately we'll have to work on that
because of
auto incrementing
primary keys
so that's where the insert
fails a bit and we had this with this
project because all of those ids are
auto increments
and we need to do a bit of footwork to
fix this but i believe this case is
common enough so that we could support
this out of the box in the end
but this is getting really geeky now
just stop it
[Laughter]
yeah
so we're doing footwork here but
um
could work better than more next
releases
all right
i got those questions
in the room the last chance to ask any
questions
before we um wrap up in those you choose
to go to the bar everybody folks if we
go to the bar if you don't want to drink
alcohol they have non-federated there
too
probably
right but no one can leave that eating
pizza um any questions from the audience
all right cool thank you very much for
filling this short notice thank you
all right so folks everyone thank you
for coming our second both in person and
virtual meetup i hope everyone enjoyed
it the slides will go up as soon as
krill emails it to us and the video is
already up on our youtube channel the ny
hack our site should be updated um
possibly tonight it updates a few times
a day so i'll be updated with the well
it won't be updated until it'll be
updated with the video but not with the
slides until we get them so it'll give
us a day or two
uh we have the august meetup and
probably hugo who couldn't make it
tonight we're going to reschedule him
for next month because he's still in
america until i guess his visa runs out
so i think he has one more month to go
and then september october november
december
um who wants to speak if you want to
speak uh send me send me an email send
me a message on slack message me on
twitter message me wherever however you
can find me if no one messages me i will
pick people randomly and have them speak
we have done that before it actually
worked out really well so i think that's
everything everyone pizza bitly pizza
poll go to my hackard.org to check out
uh the previous slides and videos check
out rstats.ai to check out the
conference videos and yeah i think
that's everything uh thank you everyone
for coming and i'll see everyone later
bye